to both of you out of 50 guys who maybe
would approach you right maybe give you
a look at the club like a bar or maybe
actually try and come talk to you out of
50 guys how many of them would you give
a chance on a gonna go on a natural date
with that you look at them all could go
natural day as in like so you look I
mean look at them and go oh I like the
vibe and energy of you enough that yeah
I'll go on a date with you I have 50
guys I guess about three about three how
about you
[__]
you know what I
want to last a minute so you know how
you're saying you know you know how
you're saying that yeah basically yeah
fair enough so you know how you're
saying like you're basing your opinion
basing your experience so out of 50 guys
there's 45 of them that you're not
experiencing that because you've
rejected them right right so all of your
experience is coming from the top five
or ten percentage and you would probably
still friend zone one or two of them
and then and then the irony is yeah 50
guys this is the reality the same Five
Guys you will give a chance at the same
Five Guys she will give a chance
probably not
what I'm trying to say is like it's it's
uh it's like the crossover is the it's a
small pool of guys who are getting the
majority of opportunity there may be
like one or two that's more your type
that you wouldn't choose and vice versa
yeah but I'm trying to say like if
you're taking a pool of men the kind of
men that you go oh actually yeah you
bring this this this all these things
that I like yeah right because you know
women have higher standards fair enough
that's just the way it is right it's
just the way it is
the majority of men don't fit all of
those standards so what's you know and
I'm not trying to remember what's the
point the problem I think the point is
just like I've got your your use it
you're getting your opinion yeah you
said from your experience but I said
that yeah yeah
oh so you're saying that we're just
saying that there is I'm making like a
blanket statement I'm just I'm just
saying that he's saying the experience
you have is with a small percentage of
men exactly so your experience isn't
very representative because you're not
like the menu deal no I'm not saying
you're disagreeing he's just furthering
the point yeah and listen and I think I
think the problem we're having is
because we're talking about
the population in general you were
talking about a very specific anecdotal
evidence I'm not saying anecdote that
evidence is irrelevant however when
we're talking about the wider Society
you are anecdotal evidence is wrong is
wrong to the um wider Society so what's
your name again Jesse Jesse I feel like
you
um you're someone who's very pragmatic
in that science and it has to be either
yes or no or on or off yes and I think
that's why I'm always going to sort of
butt heads on this specific argument
find me on Instagram and I'm gonna tell
you well
uh
sorry what I just said what's wrong
oh wait oh sorry Karen Karen also out of
what I just said what is wrong though
because that that's that's why I'm
struggling to understand right now I'm
saying that your anecdotal evidence is
wrong
um when applied to
um the entire population
oh sorry I know you can't answer sorry
but sorry I'm just going to say
something that's slightly different
anyway something I find really
interesting is how different things are
in terms of not just relationship people
committing to each other men and women
obesity rate is so different depending
on where you're from and where you live
like I'm not from London I'm from
Coventry and if I compare the girls that
I know who still live in Coventry the
life that they have compared to girls in
London it is so different and even if
you look at obviously like the stats of
obesity in America how can that be so
different to the rest of the world well
I would say that our food is worse and
and so that's a factor but you can still
make good choices and not eat the food
that is bad and eat more of the food
that's good but again so in for example
in London I'm now far more active even
just going from A to B than I would be
in Coventry like that's just a given
therefore it probably is
um I I don't know this that this is true
but I would suspect that people are
thinner in London than they are in other
areas of the country the same with
America like in New York you're probably
going to get people the majority of
people are thinner than they are outside
in other areas of America and again
something that you said earlier I can't
remember exactly what it was but it was
about men choosing not to commit because
women women were speaking around a bit
uh so what uh what uh what I was saying
was that because sex is more easily
accessible especially for you know the
percentage of men who have all the
options
um it's easier for them to reject
unless desirable women so we're taking
women who are bigger because they're
getting access to the more desirable
room a lot more easier whereas back in
the day right because it was kind of sex
outside of marriage and commitment was
taboo they wouldn't be getting that
sexual attention from the from multiple
desirable women
so then it was easier for
women who weren't as desirable to him to
get sex from him because he wasn't
getting it multiple from desirable does
that make sense yeah but have you
thought that that could be to do with
the fact that men and women now have far
more options than they ever did before I
would say that we're constantly thinking
oh like there's something better a small
percentage that's a good point but yeah
have all the options all the options
better I think most men now have more
options than they ever do no actually
it's it's actually it's the opposite and
I'll give you this example right
um like where did you say you grew up
Coventry Coventry like so for example if
you take if you take back in the day the
girl from a small English village where
social media and internet wasn't a thing
right the pool of men she would choose
were the men from her Village yeah right
now because of social media and the
thing is at the chances are she would
choose a nice average man right now
because of social media dating apps the
internet she can connect with the
Hotshot lawyer from London the
basketball player from Paris the
producer from La yeah so the average
guys in her circles are looking pretty
weak compared to the opportunities that
she has so what's actually happened is
the for the average man he's actually
got little to zero options because women
now have access to high value men and
high value men now have access to
multiple women does that make sense yeah
on top of that makes sense on top of
that back in the day women sort of knew
that because they can't necessarily they
don't tend to necessarily work they
needed a man to get through life
nowadays where women have more money
to them it's like well I'd rather I'd
rather have a man who owns the same or
more than me women would rather be
homeless than marry a beta and you can
see this because they interviewed
homeless women and a lot of them had men
they could have settled down with
and they left most of them because they
would literally rather be on the streets
than marry a guy they view as beta yeah
basically what's happened is the
necessity for men in a woman's life has
decreased right which means right which
is just the way it is I don't think it's
unfair or like it's just the way it is
which means that she can afford to be
even more picky today because she
doesn't need a man to support her
financially she can earn her own money
she can get her own place she can drive
her all of that which is great but the
byproducts of that is that it means that
if more women have become picky it means
the power has gone all to the top
percentage of men which most of the
women want and that's why you see 50 of
women being single and childless over 30
and the least happy group of women is 45
and childless that make over like 50 000
a year
and so it's like we gas women up and
this is part of body positivity we gas
women up to think they're hotter than
they are so they're sleeping with guys
that are out of their league thinking
they're going to commit to them but
they're never going to and so then these
girls think they're on this level but
they're not really on this level they're
really average and then they hit 30 35
and they still won't settle even though
that's their level
and you know how you're saying about how
um you know you came to London it seems
like everybody's in like do you say
everyone was like much like really fair
or ambition compared to commentary and
stuff yeah yeah yeah I think that goes
back to what we're saying a big part of
that is because of competition because
London is a very densely populated area
right and because there's a lot of
opportunities a lot of people who want
to make it big and whatever it is right
it's just dating career whatever you go
to one of these major cities but that's
where the competition is most fierce so
if you're going to survive let alone get
ahead you need to be competitive in that
sense I just finished doing a show in um
in in Strasbourg in France and at the
gym there all the girls right were in
incredible shape and all the guys were
incredible shape more so than East
London here right
and it's because they're all competing
for each other
everybody's competing the higher the
competition the more we have to raise
our standards in order to play the game
but why would their competition be any
higher than anywhere in the UK well I
think in that particular one you're
saying there's some baddies there I
think because there were um there was um
it's a there was a major uni campus
there so like a third of the population
of the city were like University
students do you know what I mean my
strategies in Germany right uh it's
actually in France yeah because the
German people are very uh uh uh what's
up the ethnicity the the population are
they mostly German or French uh the most
they're mostly French but Strasbourg
used to be part of Germany because I
would say that the work ethic of of the
German people was very very strong by
the competition yeah yeah yeah the thing
is true so I'm um Belgian and you know
over there in those parts of Europe the
culture is very different so I I was
there to all of us until I was about
seven I used to go back quite often I
did not see a fat person it's just the
culture there is just to you know be
that way so it makes sense that you went
to the gym even if girls and go to a gym
chances are a lot of them are very thin
so it's just the culture when it comes
down to it if you're if you're fat
you're unhealthy yeah yeah if you're
unhealthy you have less value
I'm going to take a second and read some
super chats so
guys as you know
we are trying to get it's a camera yes
ma'am you want to see what itch looks
like let's go get him a camera on top of
that guys like the video I think we were
close to a thousand likes last time I
checked so oh no we're at a thousand so
why don't we try to get a thousand two
hundred likes can we do that I think we
can do that for sure
um so let's read the super chats these
super chats are going towards isha's
camera and some other Studio updates so
send money because it's really important
too the quality of the show if you want
like you can also watch for free but
okay vinyl 46 LOL I'm one of those
invisible men I'm chilling and working
my routine average 72k a year cheap
looking car and have fairly good savings
account most girls think I'm a good guy
and ask why I'm single simply too
awesome it's like the biggest insult
like why are you single but you could
date me exactly
simply too awesome scientifically men
are more sympathetic than our women are
more sympathetic than men men are more
empathetic than women this is because
they need to understand themselves and
women sing Fred that's narcissism Pearl
for the queen for the modern woman's
ideal mind I've given you like 17 today
hun thank you I rarely super because
that's essentially one hour of work hope
that helps with the mic it does
appreciate you homie clicks why wait why
are having why does having fat friends
have to do with the conversation don't
change the goal post Rusty fuel fat
lowers the GDP it costs taxpayers
medical expenses that's what I'd be
saying
UMaine Tegan would the girls date a drug
addict that's like a functioning
cokehead considering that's also an
emotional addiction oh that's a good
question Alistar Horton body positivity
is about a lack of personal standard
shall I say
um Alistair Horton again ask yourself
which is Kinder to give someone the
harsh truth and deal with the problem or
go protect their ego and deny that the
problem's that bad Dragon
stallion1001 for the woman on the couch
if you put out KFC McDonald's and
healthy meals which do you think large
people would reach for first the junk
food Gennaro tours Gennaro lanters sell
them in XXL t-shirt motivate them to
lose weight by telling them the painful
truth then sell them another teacher
another t-shirt in a future small size
David acts Western Society is following
a woman's lead which has led us to this
place women will forever complain we
already know this boy type did my man on
the left just change ethnicities AJ
thesis guys sometimes when we have too
many guests we rotate them in and out
yeah sometimes look at it AJ thesis
people say beauty at any size and it's
not their fault instead of giving them
the information to lead a healthy
lifestyle the only person who gave
who got me into this was me and I have
to get myself but out Sam Sampson
Simpson can you imagine spending the
rest of your life being someone that
will go this far to be right pop the
popcorn boys and enjoy the decline lazy
artist if you're a member you already
saw ish's tall self
um
okay he's six seven he's six seven
changes every stream
I wonder what heels he wears
um
AJ thesis in 19
that have struggled with obesity for the
last four years being depressed doesn't
mean that you're not accountable for the
weight you gained
um
sing Oh gosh it's pronounced Siegfried
sorry I forgive you Pearl look sometimes
these names uh Marcus Moore sorry just
remind everyone that we saw ish on the
24 hour live stream Let me refresh it
real quick and just to make sure there's
no other ones if you're being baited out
today honestly
we have beef
oh yeah guys if you've watched two more
of my videos and you don't subscribe we
have beef like come on a subscription is
free a like is free if you can't donate
subscribe I know a bunch of you being
here ghost watching and it's not cool
it's not cool
um okay that is all the super chat so I
think I'm gonna close out the show so
um why don't we go around everyone say
any final thoughts you have so if you
there's something someone in the
comments you want to make your as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible